MADE PUBLIC TO ALLOW AMERICANS
TO DETERMINE WHETHER WRONG
WRONGDOING DID OCCUR.
NEW WARNINGS TONIGHT FROM THE
ADMINISTRATION ABOUT THE THREAT
FROM CHINA, TOP INTELLIGENCE
OFFICIALS SAY THE THREAT IS A
DEFINING ISSUE OF OUR TIMES.
NATIONAL SECURITY CORRESPONDENT
JENNIFER GRIFFIN LOOKS AT THE
EVIDENCE TONIGHT FROM THE
PENTAGON.
>> AMERICA’S OUTGOING
INTELLIGENCE CHIEF
JOHN RATCLIFFE IN A NEW OP-ED
WARNS THAT CHINA IS THE GREATEST
NATIONAL SECURITY THREAT FACED
BY THE UNITED STATES SINCE
WORLD WAR II.
"THE INTELLIGENCE IS CLEAR:
BEIJING INTENDS TO DOMINATE THE
U.S. AND THE REST OF THE PLANET,
ECONOMICALLY, MILITARILY, AND
TECHNOLOGICALLY."
RATCLIFFE SPOKE TO
FOXNEWS.COM, CHINA IS THE ONLY
COUNTRY CAPABLE OF CHALLENGING
AMERICAN SUPREMACY ACROSS THE
BOARD.
SUPPLY CHAIN ISSUES, FOREIGN
INVESTMENTS, CYBER ISSUES, 5G,
CHINA IS THE ONLY COUNTRY THAT
THREATENS AMERICAN SUPREMACY.
THE CHAIRMAN OF THE JOINT CHIEFS
ECHOED THAT VIEW, AS WELL.
>> THE LONGER-TERM, ALMOST
EXISTENTIAL CHALLENGE, IS GOING
TO BE CHINA.
IT JUST IS.
WE HAVE TO COME TO GRIPS WITH
THAT.
I’M NOT SAYING YOU HAVE TO HAVE
A WAR WITH CHINA.
I’M SAYING WE WANT TO PREVENT A
WAR WITH CHINA.
>> NATO IS SHIFTING ITS FOCUS
BEYOND RUSSIA.
>> CHINA DOES NOT SHARE OUR
VALUES.
IT UNDERMINES HUMAN RIGHTS.
IT BELIEVES OTHER COUNTRIES.
>> THE CHINESE COMMUNIST PARTY
CONTINUES ITS CRACKDOWN ON
HONG KONG’S PRO-DEMOCRACY
ACTIVISTS, JAILING 24-YEAR-OLD
JOSHUA WONG, AGNES CHILD, AND
26-YEAR-OLD IVAN LAM.
WHO HAS ENDURED SOLITARY
CONFINEMENT AND SENTENCED TO
PRISON FOR ORGANIZING PROTEST.
CHINA’S DEFENSE BUDGET IS NOW
THE SECOND LARGEST IN THE WORLD,
THE NAVY THE LARGEST.
>> THE CHINESE HAVE 25 SHIPYARDS
TO OUR ONE.
>> THE U.S. NAVY IS MORE LETHAL
WITH MORE PRECISION WEAPONS.
THE U.S. HAS 11 AIRCRAFT
CARRIERS, COMPARED TO CHINA’S
TWO, WHICH ARE SOVIET RELICS.
THE STATE DEPARTMENT ANNOUNCED
IT IS REDUCING VISITOR VISAS FOR
CHINESE COMMUNIST PARTY MEMBERS,
AND THEIR FAMILY MEMBERS, FROM
TEN YEARS TO ONE MONTH, DUE TO
THEIR "NEFARIOUS ACTIVITIES."
MORE THAN 1,000 VISITING CHINESE
RESEARCHERS LED THE U.S. SINCE
THE SUMMER, ACCORDING TO THE
JUSTICE DEPARTMENT, WHICH SAYS
THEY BURROWED INTO U.S. RESEARCH
LABS ON UNIVERSITY CAMPUSES AND